bienvenidos ahora veremos el concepto de
vector que aunque ya se los había
comentado antes ahora veremos cómo nos
puede ser más útil ya que lo usaremos
para resolver o resolver problemas de
proyectiles en dos dimensiones
ahora veremos un juego en el que no solo
lanzamos la pelota hacia arriba ahora
veremos qué tan lejos podemos lanzar la
pelota y cuál será el ángulo óptimo para
lanzarla así que espero que encuentren
este juego aún más divertido que el
anterior
bueno espero que ustedes recuerden cuál
es la diferencia entre vector y un
escalar recordamos que el vector tiene
una dirección
y entonces tenemos un vector
va a tener una magnitud
y una dirección
en cambio lo que es un escalar solo va a
tener
la magnitud
magnitud
un ejemplo de vector es la velocidad
recordemos que los problemas anteriores
vimos que la teníamos una velocidad en
alguno de los ejemplos era igual a menos
30 metros sobre segundo
en donde la magnitud es el número 30
y la dirección
nosotros la sabíamos por este signo de
interrogación es esto nos decían pero no
ese signo de menos
nos indicaban en la dirección hacia
arriba o hacia abajo
si me hubiera preguntado cuál era la
rapidez de la pelota antes de llegar al
suelo
yo diría que es de 30 metros por segundo
sin especificar la dirección ya que
recordemos que la rapidez es un escalar
entonces no tengo que decir hacia dónde
va en problemas de una dirección o de
una dimensión podemos decir o se tiende
a decir que un escalar de un vector es
igual al valor absoluto de la magnitud
de ese vector cuando hablamos de una
dimensión podemos decir que el escalar
es igual al valor absoluto
del vector
en este caso el escalar de velocidad es
igual a 30 al valor 30 si la velocidad
inicial era igual a 30 metros por
segundo entonces su rapidez seguiría
sino 30 metros por segundo
entonces en una dimensión la dirección
puede indicarse con signos positivos y
negativos pero cuando trabajamos en dos
direcciones o en dos dimensiones tenemos
que ser un poco más sofisticados sobre
cómo especificamos una dirección
veamos un ejemplo en donde yo tomo una
pelotita una pelotita verde
y la lanzó a 10 metros por segundo pero
no hacia arriba ahora lo voy a lanzar
con un ángulo
a 45 grados
o si les gustan los radiales van a ser
4 y entre 4 radiales
ahora mi problema se vuelve más
complicado cómo puedo especificar la
magnitud y la dirección y cómo puedo
resolver el problema sobre qué tan lejos
y qué tan alto llego bueno con suerte
justo eso es lo que espero que aprendan
durante los siguientes vídeos
bueno primero si quiero expresar esto en
rapidez y dirección magnitud y dirección
como vector tengo que especificar la
digamos que mi velocidad
inicial
es igual a 10 metros por segundo a un
ángulo de 45 grados sobre el horizonte
y bueno el horizonte está aquí
este es el sol
esta sería una manera legítima de
especificar la velocidad pero es algo
difícil trabajar con ella así que vamos
a aprender algo muy genial sobre los
vectores ya que podemos descomponer un
vector en y aquí vienen dos términos
complicados
componentes ortogonales así que pueden
decir que algo que se mueve a diez
metros por segundo con este ángulo de
hecho se está moviendo hacia arriba con
cierta velocidad y se mueve a la derecha
en este caso con cierta velocidad o en
una dirección positiva vamos a marcar
entonces tenemos que
vamos a lanzar esto y va a ver una parte
que se va a ir hacia arriba con una
velocidad y otra que se va a ir hacia en
este caso la derecha con otra velocidad
si se imaginan esto como ejes
coordinados vamos a tener que nos
movemos en la dirección o en el eje y
con cierta velocidad y nos movemos sobre
el eje x con otra velocidad y cuando que
se combinen pues de cierta manera
obtenemos este ángulo
entonces como descompongo esto en la
velocidad vertical y la velocidad
horizontal les vamos a mostrar que esto
es bastante padre y es muy directo de
obtener
entonces vamos a dibujar de nuevo
nuestro vector bueno nuestra pelotita
con el lanzamiento aquí en 45 grados
y es el valor de este vector es de 10 su
magnitud y esta es la dirección
y vamos a trabajar en un méxico ordenado
entonces estamos dibujando el vector con
su magnitud su dirección y vamos a ver
qué resulta que nuestra componente a voy
a dibujar el no se ve que nuestra
componente vertical de la velocidad será
igual de la componente vertical de esta
pelotita que sube va a ser igual a éste
a este elemento o este lado y que la
magnitud
horizontal va a ser ésta
este componente
vean que esto es un triángulo y no es
cualquier triángulo es un triángulo
rectángulo
tenemos aquí un ángulo recto y eso es
importante que los componentes del
vector formen ángulos rectos para así
poder aplicar las mejores fórmulas
trigonométricas
bueno veamos cómo resulta esto a qué
velocidad voy hacia arriba y cuál es el
componente vertical de este vector
bueno tenemos aquí
recordamos esta vendría siendo del
triángulo nuestra hipotenusa este
nuestro lado opuesto o cateto opuesto y
este sería nuestro cateto adyacente
entonces recordemos
nuestros elementos de la trigonometría
tenemos el seno
el coseno y la tangente y si no han
visto trigonometría o no se acuerdan les
recomiendo que revisen los vídeos de
trigonometría que tenemos para que
puedan repasar y aprender estos
conceptos que vamos a usar cuál de las
razones trigonométricas nos sirve para
involucrar el cateto opuesto y la
hipotenusa
bueno tenemos que es ese
y tenemos que el seno de nuestro ángulo
en este caso vamos a llevarlo teta es
igual al cateto opuesto
sobre la hipotenusa
y bueno en este caso nuestro cateto
opuesto
va a ser nuestro componente vertical a
nuestra velocidad vertical aunque
realmente esta variable jamás la he
visto en mis clases de física
entre nuestra hipotenusa que su valor es
de 10
y si despejamos lo que nos interesa
bueno también conocemos que el seno
de 45 grados bueno tenemos que esto es
un seno de 45 grados si despejamos
nuestra velocidad vertical va a ser
igual a 10 por el seno de 45 grados
y si quiero conocer mi componente
horizontal está queremos que es nuestra
velocidad vertical esta es nuestra
velocidad horizontal y si quiero conocer
cuál es mi velocidad ahora horizontal
bueno me recuerdo que nuestros elementos
trigonométricos que involucran el cateto
adyacente y la hipotenusa es el coseno
entendemos que el coseno del ángulo
theta es igual a el cateto
adyacente
entre la hipotenusa que viene siendo
nuestra velocidad horizontal entre la
hipotenusa que viene siendo 10 y nuestra
velocidad horizontal despejada queda
como 10 o seno de 45 grados y en el
siguiente vídeo resolveremos estas
ecuaciones